[Music]
Monday night we saw part one of a two
nights Bachelorette event also known as
witnessing the breakdown of a human
named Chad minute-by-minute that's just
a taste here's the deal
Evan and Chad have beef Chad says Evan
tried to push him out of the way on a
group date Evan says Chad grabbed him
and ripped his shirt for no reason
already he had three kids like he had
his chance at love this shirt man
guys this episode got so tense I
literally started crouching down away
from my TV in fear in fear now as
Extreme as Chad does sound he maintains
that he was retaliating against Evans
bullying not starting fights then Evan
went and told the final word on all
things bachelor aka Chris Harrison that
chad was a problem in the house I think
it's an issue with this guy and Chris
told Chad he needed to settle things and
Chad said this I cut everyone hears legs
off and arms off and there's gonna be
torsos and then I'm gonna throw them in
the pool I'm gonna got this entire damn
thing
yeah so whose side are you on here Evans
or Chad's
let me know on Twitter I'm sweating
right now
[Music]